[applause]
Gibbs: Thanks, guys.
Well, you know, thus far
I've told you about two parts
of our end to end Java story
this far tonight.
I've told you about
our Eclipse integration,
which allows you
to build all of this
in one single location.
And I told you about
our Java language support
for App Engine, which gives you
a place to deploy it.
But that's only actually
told you about half the story,
building the back end
of your application.
The other half,
building your front end,
has some
serious challenges too.
If you've ever built
a modern web application before,
you know you have to deal
with a lot of different
browser quirks.
Different browsers
have different ways
of running different
JavaScript code.
Once you've solved all those
different browser quirks,
then you have to worry
about how large
your JavaScript code base gets.
When you have a lot
of JavaScript code,
it's not only
difficult to manage,
but it can become fragile.
Just a few changes
in one place or another
can cause it to be upset.
Once you have
the app working then,
you usually
have to optimize it.
You have to optimize it
to get the JavaScript
to be faster,
to get your download
to be smaller,
to reduce your bandwidth
and so on.
In short,
all of this becomes
a tedious,
error-prone process,
and each bug you encounter
takes you further away
from what you actually
wanted to do
which was build
a great web application.
So Google Web Toolkit,
the last chapter
in tonight's end to end
Java story,
addresses precisely this.
Now for those of you
who are not familiar
with Google Web Toolkit,
the premise is simple.
It allows you to write
your application in Java,
both the client
and the server,
and then it compiles
that Java code
down to JavaScript.
Now when you do this,
you gain a number of benefits.
Since your code was completely
written in Java,
you can test
and debug that locally
using a standard
Java debugger
for both your front end
and your back end code.
Then when
your app is complete,
you can compile
that Java code to JavaScript.
And that JavaScript is in
a standard JavaScript file.
You can serve
from any web server.
Now when it's doing
that compilation,
it also does a number
of optimizations to your code
to make it as small
and as fast as possible.
It also takes into account
every major browser
on the market,
including IE, Firefox,
Chrome and more,
so that your code accounts
for all those browser quirks
that I mentioned.
That means you can spend
a lot less time in QA
and worrying if your app
is blown up.
And finally,
Google Web Toolkit
generates the source code
for each browser independently.
That means that when you use
a Google Web Toolkit app,
you only download
exactly the code that you need
to run on your browser
for that app.
And we think taken together
these increases
in developer productivity
and making better code
for your application
and making it more portable
and running on more browsers,
is a win, win, win
that's tough to beat
with handwritten JavaScript.
Now you might be wondering,
why am I telling you
about GWT tonight?
GWT's been around
for a while.
In fact, we open sourced
all of GWT back in 2006.
Well, I'm talking
about it tonight
because for the first time
we've been able to bring
Google Web Toolkit
and App Engine together
so that you can write
a single application,
both the front and the--
front end and the back end
together.
It's fast.
The applications
you create are fast,
standards based,
and can be deployed anywhere,
on-site or on App Engine.
And they're all written
in Java, a single language.
Now many of you
probably haven't seen
Google Web Toolkit
in action before.
So to help with that,
I'm gonna invite Andrew
back onstage,
and he's gonna take
the guest book application
that you've already seen
and he's gonna inject
some Ajaxy goodness
using Google Web Toolkit.
Andrew.
Andrew: Thanks, Kevin.
Well, it's hard to imagine
how I could improve
my guest book application.
[laughter]
But I'm gonna try.
So here I want to bring
my web application,
my guest book application
into the modern world
with an Ajax running
'cause I hear
it's all the rage.
And I'm gonna do that
with Google Web Toolkit.
And I'm gonna inject,
as Kevin calls it,
the Ajaxy goodness.
And what this is going to be
is no longer it's going
to be a JSP page
submitting to a servlet
and then redirecting back.
It's going to be here.
It's going to have JavaScript.
It's going to submit
my entries to the server
on the back end
and then list out entries here
without ever leaving the page.
So similar experience
to most web apps these days.
So I'm gonna go
back into Eclipse.
And I've actually created
that project already.
And I'm just gonna show you
what it looks like
and what
it looks like to work
with Google Web Toolkit
on top of App Engine.
So let me close out
the other one,
and let me open up this.
Now if you tried to build
an Ajax application,
you'll know
that you have to worry
about a lot
of different things.
You have to know
about JavaScript
for many different browsers
and all the quirks.
Luckily, you're not gonna
have to do that here.
There are a few different--
There's some changes
you'll notice
from the last project,
notably in the package
structure.
So if I look here,
I have client, server,
and shared packages.
Everything
in my client directory
is going to create
my user interface
on the browser in JavaScript.
So the Java files are going
to be cross-compiled
into JavaScript
and run
in my user's browser here.
My user interfaces
is built
here in the user interface
Java class.
And you can see
I'm using widgets,
creating text boxes
and buttons.
And I'm using click handlers
just like I would
in desktop programming.
What this is doing
is providing--
excuse me, providing
a higher level of abstraction
on top of JavaScript
across all browsers
so that you can focus
on the application logic
and not the browser quirks.
So this code is going
to run as JavaScript.
In my server package,
that code is going to run
as Java bytecode
on the server.
Now remember, on the client,
it's just JavaScript.
There are no applets.
On the server it's bytecode.
And then shared,
because we're using Java
to model our client code,
it's going to be JavaScript,
we can actually share objects
across both client and server.
So if you remember,
we had the entry object
that we annotated earlier.
I'm actually using this
across both the JavaScript
on my client
and my server.
Now you're hearing
a lot about compilation.
And you may be wondering,
am I going to have to compile
every time I want to make
a change and see what happens?
Luckily, you won't
have to do that.
So if I bring up
my development environment here,
I have the guest book
application running.
And let's say, uh--
So you can see I have another
long-winded post here.
I changed my post here
to another long-winded post
by someone.
And I don't like that.
I want to change it back
to "posted by."
So I'll go back here
and I'll find that text,
go into my user interface.
We'll just say "another
long-winded and pointless post."
Just click "refresh"
just like I would
with JavaScript.
And so I made
the change in Java,
reflected in the JavaScript
here in my development
environment.
Now the next thing we can do
because we're using Java
across the entire application,
is we can debug
with the standard Java tools
that we're used to.
So let's say
I'm having a problem
with this list here,
and I wanna debug that.
So I can go back into
my Java source.
I can go into this
on success method,
and I'll set
a break point here on "list."
Then I'll go back
and I'll create an entry.
When I create an entry,
that's going to trigger
a refresh of the list.
Well, let's see, it should
trigger a break point.
Let's--I probably
started it not in debug.
So let's try that again.
I'm gonna start it up
in debug.
Now it's important to note
that you're not
just debugging the--
Oh, looks like
we still had it running.
You're not just debugging
on the client or the server.
You can debug across both.
So I can debug
that same Java--
that same entry.Java file
across both the server
and then go and look at it
across the client as well.
So let's see
if we have that going now.
So now it's
started up the page,
and then it triggered
my break point.
This means I can step
through the code
just like I would
in any Java application.
I can inspect variables
and see what's going
on up here.
Now you may think
that's not very--
not very amazing,
but remember
that this is JavaScript
that we're debugging.
This is Ajax code
that we're actually debugging.
So the last point
I want to make
is just a glimpse
under the hood
of Google Web Toolkit
and also a little bit about
the performance aspects.
So if you want to see--
Let's say I wanted to see
what the actual JavaScript
for this method looked like.
I could do that.
I could go into
the web archive directory.
This is where the JavaScript's
going to be stored.
And I could look for that.
So let's see,
I think it's called
"function onsuccess."
And so here's that method,
and I can see the JavaScript,
which is created
from the Java.
Now it's not just Java
to JavaScript compilation
that's going on here, though,
or cross-compilation.
Because we're using Java,
which is a static language,
we can do a lot of analysis
across the code base
for compiler optimizations.
I won't go into those here,
but the point is that
your app gets faster
every time a new version
of Google Web Toolkit comes out.
So the end result
of using Google Web Toolkit
on App Engine is, one,
it's a very tightly
integrated environment,
so it's very easy
to use both together.
You can use them separately
as well if you want.
But its productivity gains,
as a developer,
but for your in user
it's also performance gains
because your code's
going to be a lot smaller
that the user
has to download,
and the actual JavaScript's
going to be
a lot faster as well.
Thanks, Kevin.
[applause]